Peggy 18
Detroit is Quantic Dream's latest
project it takes place in the near
future in the city of Detroit and it
features the character of Kara that we
introduced in this short video back in
2011 we're incredibly excited to
announce it here in our own country in
Paris at Paris games week there are
androids that Luke speak and move
exactly like human beings so they're
they're really in this society and they
are used to do different tasks and
different things we didn't want to do
sci-fi we didn't want to invent any
technology that doesn't exist in labs
today we wanted the world to look
familiar
to the player so we really feel like how
I I know this place this is a real place
but at the same time be surprised at
each corner we developed this short
video featuring this character of Kara I
think back in 2011 and it was a very
very exciting piece for us it was a very
interesting journey working with Valerie
corridas great actress but it left me a
little bit frustrated because I wanted
to know what would happen to this
character when she leaves the factory
and what the world would be like and
that what she would think of it and this
is how Detroit started
Detroit is really a fascinating place
it's a great place for industry but also
for creative people for artists of all
kinds and we thought that well if one
day an Android the industry has to
appear somewhere it should be in Detroit
it would be a logical place in in many
many ways we went there and really
explored the city inside out and yes
we've seen the abandon churches and the
abandoned places but at the same time we
saw fantastic places we met fantastic
people and we could really feel the
energy that was there and that was very
very inspiring
Detroit is featuring a brand new 3d
engine we love to do one engine per game
which is a little bit crazy but the idea
is of course to really leverage the
power of the console and really try to
offer a visual experience and a gameplay
experience that will be hopefully much
better than on the previous generation
of consoles and we try to use the
technology to improve the graphics but
also to improve the emotion that the
player will feel having better facial
animation having better lighting having
larger environments with a lot of life
and passers-by and things happening
wherever you look around
I think there are some common points
with what we've done in the past it's
based on storytelling it's based on
emotion and the emotional involvement of
the player in the experience but I think
that the game has its own voice and it's
really a different experience from
beyond and from heavy rain in many many
ways the entire game is really built
around this idea that the player is the
co-writer of the experience and that he
will tell his own story through his
actions so we can have a very very
significant impact on the story and more
than the story on the world itself all
theme is really what does it mean to be
human what does it mean to have emotions
and this kind of things and this is
really what we want to talk about
ps4 for the players